what is the lamest moment from your game
series I know honey but I love Axl but
when he introduced himself a king of
cartoons like names Axl got it memorized
this is versus the GameSpot show that
pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot-button issues against
each other this week we've got a
square-enix Civil War as we pick Kingdom
Hearts against Final Fantasy fighting
for Kingdom Hearts is Lucy James who
actually chokes up on multiple occasions
during the filming of this video
due to the sheer nostalgia of it all and
I give you the case for Final Fantasy is
two more Husain who imported the
Japanese version of Final Fantasy 9 and
then started learning Japanese just so
he could figure out what was going on
he's you're going to argue the corner
for their game over the course of three
rounds with the overall winner being
decided by you though wonderful viewers
last week's debate to figure out the
best Batman Arkham game saw Lucy win
with 55% of the vote for her Arkham City
argument but to vote for who you think
argue their case better in this episode
we're going to be throwing up a
clickable poll right here on YouTube
right let's get into the debate
[Music]
tomorrow hello I see you've come as a
member of Final Fantasy 15 boy band
first of all what is this personal
attack on my appearance classic Kingdom
Hearts fan just going to the appearance
secondly I was up all night reading
about Final Fantasy and this is what you
look like after you do that Lucy let's
begin story slash character let's go the
floor is yours Luce you tell us about
Kingdom Hearts this story tell us in
detail about Kingdom Hearts story please
make it make sense because I've played
every single one of those games and I
don't know what's going on it all
started a long time ago with the
Keyblade Wars No so Kingdom Hearts is
story I'm going to begin by
acknowledging the faults in that it is
yes very convoluted but ultimately at
the core of it one when you're playing
Kingdom Hearts it doesn't really matter
because you do you can get through the
game without really understanding the
intricacies of everything
the thing about Kingdom Hearts is
interesting the characters as well is
that they did such a smart thing by not
only creating new characters like Sora
nominate Kyrie weather but they also
integrated it with these two franchises
well multiple franchises that people
know and love Final Fantasy and Disney
and that means that they create this
story and feature characters that
everyone already has an emotional bond
with because you've basically grown up
with these characters and so that's why
overall the main story of Kingdom Hearts
is like it's a backdrop because that's
not really why you're that you're there
because you want to recreate your
childhood by playing around with these
characters either whose worlds that you
know so well part of Kingdom Hearts is
appeal is it's because it's our
generation who played it and you think
about the age we were when we play
Kingdom Hearts you play games and you'd
be like I don't care what I'm doing but
all I know is I've got Donald and Goofy
by my side and I'm whacking the crap out
of some heartless and I'm saving the
princesses of heart and whatever and I
don't know I'm just working my way to
that final word the story is at the
heart of Final Fantasy it's always been
a story driven series and because of
that its characters are also incredibly
important to the entire franchise it's
like it's like everyone comes to Final
Fantasy 8 for the story and whether you
like it or not every story presents
something different and interesting it's
different fee matically so
trying to tackle some different element
of and narrative like for example 15 is
all about like the road trip the
friendship the coming-of-age story lads
on tour you know 7 is all about you know
eco-terrorism and well 12 is Star Wars
and it's a great take on Star Wars very
few franchises out there can take kind
of like the the framework of Star Wars
and the blueprint Star Wars and spin it
in a way that's interesting and good and
that's one of the ones that kind of
really sticks out I don't think that
game gets enough love for doing that and
every single one always has a clear
defined kind of like narrative thread
through it it might be ridiculous at a
time you might not like it but it's
always clear and understandable and the
characters along the way I mean Final
Fantasy is responsible for some of
gaming's most iconic characters
characters like surfer off for example
you take surf or cloud you know my
favorites like zel in a and squall in a
and also the enemies as well like I
don't want to rag on Kingdom Hearts
because I love Kingdom Hearts but like
the enemies in that the Heartless are
kind of just like you get you have the
like the organization team but you also
have the regular Disney villains like I
think II know how to strengthen a use
characters like Hades and Maleficent or
to greater effect because they are
basically really there's amongst the
other Disney villains but the vast
majority of times you're not finding
them you're finding the squishy black
things and then that's the income and
that's the kind of like end goal
whereas Final Fantasy is got all these
iconic act I mean you've got a final
fantasy character in on your mark yeah
we didn't really have like mughals it's
not enemy moogles like behemoth every
aspect of Final Fantasy is heavy on
characterization give in my game you can
summon Chicken Little in my game you can
summon knights of the round the next
topic is gameplay
take it away every Final Fantasy game is
unique in its unique but it also shares
a lineage between it there's always like
familiar gameplay touch points like
upgrading and that kind of stuff but
each each game will provide you
something unique to the way you
interface with the game so like 7 is
known for its materia systems a is known
for its flawed but interesting draw
system which I was a big fan of the
gameplay for Final Fantasy since this
beginning has also defined the way RPGs
are played and a lot of ways to the
point where people yearn to play those
types of games we've just had a new
release octopops traveler and the whole
shtick one of the main kind of like
selling points of that is it's a classic
RPG experience and it's classic because
it leans heavily on Final Fantasy within
each Final Fantasy game it's not just an
RPG type experience where you're
fighting battles everyone provides
something unique to else to do to do as
well like seven had a bit way you were
like riding a bike a motorbike it has
the the cards the card game play where
you're like basically playing a
competitive card game most people who
create RPGs at some point or another
will look at a Final Fantasy game and be
like take inspiration from it so when it
comes to RPGs there's not really any
other franchise that can prove to or can
say they has gameplay as strong as Final
Fantasy the game played Kingdom Hearts
is like people will oversimplify and say
just button mashing and just like
hitting access never again occasionally
triangle and then it can be dolls it can
be dumbed down to that but ultimately at
the same time it is an RPG you get
upgrade points you get to unlock new
abilities and the thing that I love
about Kingdom Hearts is that it's so
mobile and you are constantly on the
move if you're doing things properly you
are like executing these rad combos
you're using your party members you're
moving all around it I think the Kingdom
Hearts
credit is the fact that you have all
these different worlds and like I can
talk at length about how great is to be
in the world but the way that the gate
the worlds influence the gameplay so you
can swap out your party members who each
have their own abilities
like location-specific like those limit
moves like the awesome huge ones like
depending on your party members which
kind of just makes things mixes things
up a bit
also you whack people on face you have
magic you hit people the giant key and
you have different Drive forms and then
you get two key blades and you're just
smacking people with two keys and it's
rad literally all of this take it from
finite offense I know but not every
single element of that is one of them
it's pretty much but it's like the more
like now final fantasy combat is
basically becoming Kingdom Hearts now
with 15 it's way more like Kingdom it
feels a lot more like Kingdom Hearts but
the DNA of both games is strongly still
fun or fancy though ya know but it's
good to see them finally coming together
bringing the audiences together and
hopefully they kind of benefit from each
other and 15 certainly combat certainly
benefit from being a little more like
Kingdom Hearts yeah both the DNA is so
super super fancy but I think in some
regards I prefer the more action like
havoc very conveniently left out the
gummi ships I didn't we
well afraid Radford legacy let's go
so I think Kingdom Hearts like where my
marble like Avengers infinity wars the
most ambitious crossover event in movie
history Kingdom Hearts is certainly
probably one of the most ambitious
course of events literally the story
about how Kingdom has happened is that
no more son was playing Super Mario
Sunshine he was like oh I'd love I'm
really inspired by this movement I'd
love to make a game of this we haven't
really got a character who's is famous
as Mario but Mickey Mouse would be good
and then it turns out Disney and Square
Enix we're in the same building
Disney exact on a square exact we're the
same lifts a kiss and they pitched the
idea and it was a it's real elevator
pitch that is a crossover event that
like one in however many million things
that would happen let alone for the
games to actually exist and for all to
kind of just work together so well and
to explore these Disney properties in a
new way with a new overarching storyline
that's not the same
that we've seen over and over again in
Disney movies and for a nice spin on it
I kind of like that and the thing is
it's like if by the time three comes out
it'll live in 13 years and the fact that
the fans are so passionate about it like
that can't be like people are still so
incredibly passionate about games legacy
of Kingdom Hearts is not know the legs
of Kingdom Hearts is they make games
that was so good and so special to so
many people these people haven't been
able to let go of that and it's still so
passionate about it years and years
later and we both are live yeah and it's
it's a kind of very special thing that
we managed to do I agree with all that
and it's very much echoed by Final
Fantasy like like the legacy of Final
Fantasy is the legacy of RPG gaming like
it's helped like I said before it's
helped defined RPGs it helped bring
people to RPGs that may not have before
it's defined console generations Square
Enix going to PlayStation for example
from Nintendo that was a huge deal and
it was business considerations that
ultimately made that happen with the CD
versus a cartridge but still that was
massive and like in a lot of ways Final
Fantasy is what pushed PlayStation to
success each of those games the legacy
is like far-reaching and like you said
music the official murmur has done
amazing work in all of Square Enix's
games like similarly in matter son he's
created some of the most iconic
memorable video game music whether it's
you know the prelude theme from Final
Fantasy the series or like one winged
angel again like I don't want it I don't
mean this in a way to be like Oh Kingdom
Hearts there's a reason why Kingdom
Hearts until this point has relied so
heavily on Final Fantasy 4 it's kind of
like star characters there's a reason
why when we were an interview where
we've no no more Essam we said we're the
Final Fantasy characters and he said man
people really want Final Fantasy
characters I'm not a way though that you
think that Kingdom Hearts is maybe
moving away from yeah I'm glad he's
doing that no I'm glad it's not relying
on that but I'm also kind of sad that
they're not in there those those
appearances were some of my favorite
moments but like the legacy of Final
Fantasy is like indisputable its
far-reaching it's critical to gaming's
history and it probably will be to its
future for a little while longer
let us know who you think won the debate
by voting in our poll at the top right
corner of the video or if you're over on
GameSpot calm by putting your thoughts
in the comments section below
it'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quick fire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how Tom and
Lucy get on ladies first
thank you who would win in a fight
between Mickey and Cloud Strife Cloud
Strife has the Buster Sword which is how
does he even wield it look at his frame
how can how is he gonna be able to hit
Mickey with that because Mickey is so
quick and nimble he'll be your just
dodge and rings around him he is great
he do slow it costs low I've solved it
you've cost low and Mickey opening slow
or even stop it costs top and then
posture sword to the face Mickey is dead
what is the lamest moment from your game
series I know honey but I love axel
but when he introduced himself the king
of cartoons like name's axel got it
memorized I think I think for mine it's
obvious there's a keyblade and a gun
blade but what would your blade be paper
blade usually you totally have a
beyblade
if you like on the hill they explain
Kingdom Hearts the story in one sentence
the ultimate battle light that doesn't
even begin to explain their story at all
how do you say no it's not possible what
character from your game would you most
like to have dinner with axel got it
memorized thank you I wanna go on a
romantic romantic dinner do I wanna go
on a broad dinner okay deep do romantic
dinners that's why
romantic dinner I would pick quistis
twisters yeah
she's in education so she's smart she's
the interesting conversation she is
totally got that hot teacher vibe going
on she's got a whip I'm declaring this
round remember to get your voice heard
in our poll or in the comment section
below and tell us who you think argue
their case better and if you enjoyed
this episode of vs. make sure to hit
that subscribe button as we'll have new
episodes this show every Wednesday
thanks for watching
[Music]
you